this is me after a night out furiously
texting and sharing photos but tonight
here's all I've got
oh and I made this one confused let me
tell you how I got here I'll be honest I
haven't been to a real party in about a
long time in my day we didn't take
selfies and snapchat whatever at least
this guy thinks I look 21 tonight
I'm at the you had to be there party
it's called that because it's a phone
free event no photos no texting no what
zapping no facebooking no snapchatting
no MySpace but the party planners don't
just trust you to put your phone away
[Music]
okay I'm cool promise the case is made
by yonder a San Francisco startup and
the only way to unlock the pouch is to
leave the party and tap it on one of
these disk things but inside the party
it's no phone or camera all the time
thus the stick figure reenactments of
what happened after two and a half hours
of phone free partying here's what I
learned
number one we use our phones as a social
crutch Here I am being super
uncomfortable without friends waiting
for a drink usually I pass the time
looking at Facebook or Twitter or
Instagram without the phone I
legitimately felt lost and awkward
really awkward number two
we spend a lot of time capturing the
moment not living in it
it's so easy to take photos on our
phones that we spend so many great life
moments looking at a screen sure you can
use an old-school film camera or you can
just decide to dance number three we
think every moment is meant for sharing
there were things I saw and immediately
wanted to post right then and there it's
partly why performers like Chris Rock
Donald Glover and David Blaine are
starting to use Yonder at their events
and then it was all over with one tap on
the unlocking mechanism I was free or
maybe I was actually trapped again in
the digital world hold on I've got to
share this great shot on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and snapchat right now
damn I looked good tonight
[Music]